2007 verschwand die kleine maddie
seitdem keine spur von ihr
aber jetzt gibt es einen tatverdächtigen
den deutschen christian bgi wird nun und
zusammenhang mit dem verschwinden des
damals drei jährigen britischen mädchens
madeleine mccann ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig stellt
den 43 jetzt unter mordverdacht bei den
beschuldigten handelt es sich um einen
mehrfach vorbestraften sexualstraftäter
der jetzt gerade eine haftstrafe hier in
deutschland ab sich für eine andere tat
ist die identität des mannes also dass
verdächtigen bekannt
er hat zugriff auf zwei fahrzeuge das
eine ist ein wohnwagen vom typ vw t3
westfalia ist ein modell aus den frühen
80ern und der farbton ist sehr markante
sehr alt und nicht mehr im besten
zustand mit einem weißen oberen in einem
gelben unteren bereich der andere ist
ein jaguar der eine dunkle farbe hat
dabei handelt es sich um einen xj r6 er
ist nicht besonders selten oder
einzigartig aber in der gegend könnte
ein jaguar aufgefallen sein
die ermittler wollen nun unter anderem
wissen wer hat die fahrzeuge 2007 um die
tatzeit am dritten mai an der
portugiesischen algarve gesehen und in
welchem zusammenhang wurden die pkw
damals abgestellt möglicherweise an
ungewöhnlichen oder abgelegenen orten
gibt es zeugen die den nutzer der
fahrzeuge kennen beide autos sind
aktuell verschwunden
klar ist bisher nur der beschuldigte war
nicht halter des vw busses der halter
ist als tatverdächtiger auszuschließen
könnte personen geben die in der
vergangenheit angst hatten auf die
polizei zuzugehen
ich möchte mich an diejenigen wenden die
informationen haben hat der mann in der
nacht im vertrauen mit ihnen gesprochen
er sitzt momentan im gefängnis daher ist
es vielleicht ein guter zeitpunkt sich
an die britische deutsche oder
portugiesische polizei zu wenden
die ermittler veröffentlichten außerdem
bilder von zwei häusern
die beamten fragen wer kann angaben zu
den gebäuden oder zimmern machen
er hat sich dort schon einmal
aufgehalten gibt es personen die mit den
beiden häusern in verbindung stehen
der verdächtige beginn möglicherweise
sexuelle übergriffe oder
vergewaltigungen während seiner zeit in
portugal gesucht werden nun weitere
opfer
ich habe keinerlei informationen ob
maddie am leben ist oder nicht seit 2011
haben wir den fall des verschwindens von
maddie mccann als vermisstenfall
behandelt und ich werde mich weiter
darauf konzentrieren zu verstehen was am
dritten mai 2007 passiert ist noch
einmal ich möchte an die menschen
appellieren wenn sie diesen mann kennen
ihn identifizieren können und ihm in
einem der fahrzeuge oder einer der
telefonnummern in verbindung bringen
können
bitte melden sie sich für hinweise die
zur aufklärung der tat führen ist eine
belohnung von 10.000 euro ausgelobt